steve o bonsoir donc vous êtes l'un des
héros de jackass l'émission de
télévision qui cartonne sur m6 lie et
dans le monde entier alors si vous quand
on vous demande pourquoi vous faites ça
vous répondais je n'aime pas travailler
je n'aime pas étudié et je veux qu'on ne
m'oublie jamais voilà c'est un petit peu
votre devise d'une certaine façon soleil
a way un petit peu
cela fait tout le temps comme un store
de rock eelv et rockstar sans chercher à
faire des chansons bretonnes à
comprendre puisque vivant sans de
l'émission c'est incroyable dit mois
estivaux bon faire ça est ce que il faut
être masochiste ou km
qu'il faut avoir un besoin tu hérites
d'attention d'attirer des soins
vos parents c'est vrai qu'ils préfèrent
dire à leurs amis que vous êtes mort
plutôt que de dire ce que vous faites
vraiment
[Rires]
mais pas dit ça ils disent que vous êtes
vous dit quoi quand un gosse se tue
après avoir fait un truc qui l'a vu dans
une de vos émissions
que
je t'encourage et des gamins à limiter
quand même
cela j'étais à nice bon je veux qu'on
s'intéresse à moi et puis j'ai pas envie
de partager des petites avec les autres
alors moi je vais pas m'arrêter je veux
que les gens s'intéressent à moi quand
ça intéresse beaucoup à vous la preuve
c'est que vous êtes ici ce soir mais si
c'était pour vous faire du mal et pour
sauter dans la mer des trucs comme ça
est ce que vous auriez pas mieux fait
d'être militaire
peut-être
dire que moi je ne sais pas d'abord une
bonne influence sur les enfants moi ce
que j'essaie de faire c'est de divertir
alors il ya beaucoup de gens qui se font
passer une épouvantable journée est pire
en voyant ma vidéo il s'amuse à les
distraits et ça je suis fier de ça est
ce que emma vous pouvez remonter le tee
shirt de steve o pour qu'on voie le
tatouage que vous avez dans le dos il a
le tatouage le plus nul que j'ai jamais
vue voilà c'est ça gueule juillet
alors dites moi c'est quoi que vous avez
fait le plus dur dans la vie steve o est
ce que c'est vous injecter de la vodka
en intraveineuse
[Rires]
en tout cas c'est pas moi c'est pas loin
du
record
peut-être le truc est plus dur c'est en
fait que cette ferme où l'aja ça ça sert
[Applaudissements]
je veux montrer un numéro là si ça vous
intéresse mais
avant d'être payé pour faire le mariole
je faisais des spectacles pour des pubs
pour avoir regardé des poissons à l'oeil
regardez un peu
les traits
à
craon gaz à les attendait
[Musique]
ouais
y aurait lui même
l'imérien presque au laos où les ballons
de foot là
les voiles et voilà
alors soyez allez-y mollo quand même
ma maison je suis traité moins
d'américains la con là
j'avais une photo de georges pour le
mettre sur ma tête comme ça on a envie
de me taper dessus un peu plus fort
enfin peu importe
ok on est prêts là
attendez
fort
n'oubliez pas qu'il est américain
les gars merci à
jeter bien n'oubliez pas d'acheter mon
dvd
vous avez déjà est-ce que vous avez déjà
sacrifié des poulets sur scène comme
marilyn manson and à la digue à djeddah
dire coco aussi tout ce qu'il faut faire
c'est est étranglé les poulets pour
avant l'ère cause touche pas si c'est
vraiment qu'est ce que vous pensez steve
o des néo conservateurs américains qui
ont pris le pouvoir aujourd'hui aux
états unis autour de george w bush
tout est de ma gueule ou quoi là enfin
moi je sais même pas ce que c'est qu'un
néo conservateurs
sur ce plateau il s'appelle william
kristol mesdames et messieurs il a
rencontré rick flens à huy
américaine du
magazine gq a explosé
plus les trois autres villes un champion
exprès avec ça les raisons c'est
dangereux de fumer dites moi alors les
néoconservateurs ça vous inquiète pas le
fait que george w bush soit entouré
d'une bande de mecs qui veulent faire
régner comme ça leur paie sur le monde
ça vous inquiète pas
parler de politique je veux dire
tout ce que j'ai à dire c'est que je
pense pas qu'il y ait eu de d'armes de
destruction massive en iraq oil on s'en
fout si on avait
non seulement la paume et hermann
attention l'utiliser
vous voulez pas aller payer repas gascon
voulait prendre c'était des champs
pétrolifères vous voulez le pétrole nous
dira que c'est ça qui nous intéressait
super pagnol aux etats unis confrontés
avec ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu